hey what's up I'm Kim HD here and this
this is not a normal phone
so you know they say the best way to act
is if everyone else acted like you then
the world would be great to be the
change you want to see in the world
right so in this world of constant
E-Waste and this fight for better more
repairable gadgets this is called the
fairphone 4 and it's aiming to do
exactly that so at first glance it's a
pretty basic looking phone it's 579
Euros or about 650 and that gets you a
clean basic design flat front and back
curves at the corners a little on the
big side but nothing we haven't seen
before that's a 6.3 inch 1080p display
up front a metal frame a fingerprint
sensor on the power button and USBC at
the bottom and it has 5G which previous
earphones didn't have looks pretty good
but that's that's just at first glance
this phone is designed from the ground
up to be sustainable modular repairable
and upgradable by you
that is very unlike any other phone out
right now so how do they do it well you
start with the basics you saw the
packaging which is recycled paper and
cardboard printed with soy ink so this
packaging is entirely sustainable then
the phone itself is pretty easy to get
into for anyone not just professionals
anyone so you get into this Notch down
here built into the corner of the phone
and that lets you pull off the soft
touch fully recycled plastic back cover
and that lets you get into all the parts
of this phone so the 3 900 milliamp hour
battery that can be easily popped out
replaced just like the good old days and
then the rest of the pieces are all
easily accessible by just 12 screws so
you just need a little Phillips
screwdriver to jump right in and then
each of the parts pops right out like a
puzzle piece so it isn't necessarily
individual components but the camera and
speaker housing up here at the top can
be removed and replaced pretty easily if
you take off the bottom you can replace
your speaker module for a new one I
literally just popped a ribbon cable off
and was able to remove just just the USB
type-c port from this phone so if your
Port breaks or gets loose you don't have
to replace all of the inside of your
phone you don't have to pay someone an
exorbitant amount of money you don't
have to throw it all out and buy a whole
new phone you just head over to
fairphone's website and scroll through
the list of modules and pieces that they
sell and buy exactly which one you need
then when you get it you take the phone
apart pretty quickly and easily and can
replace it so like I said it's not like
other phones you know these days in a
normal smartphone if one little part
breaks typically that's you know you
have very limited options where
fairphone envisions a future where
anyone can identify something broken or
something they want to upgrade and just
do it themselves so that'll include your
battery your rear-facing camera your
front-facing camera your speaker your
earpiece your USB port and of course
your display the whole front the display
is easily removable with a single ribbon
cable and that replacement to the user
is 80 euros and honestly very easy to do
yourself off unlike pretty much every
other smartphone this phone scores a 10
out of 10 repair score from iFixit
there's no glue no complex screws
nothing to make it unnecessarily
difficult to take apart and it comes
with a five year warranty including a
promise to support the phone and sell
the spare parts for five years after the
phone comes out it's a dream so I am a
huge fan of this Vision but it's worth
noting it's not perfect right this is
where the inner instinct to review
everything comes out for me like if you
were to buy this
650-ish dollar phone there are some
obvious trade-offs so let's just for the
sake of example take the fair phone up
against if you're going to buy a phone
something else of similar price like
pixel 6. so for one the fair phone the
fair phone is a thick phone with about
three C's right so it's a little bit
thicker and heavier than a pixel but
just enough where it's not bad but you
can tell the difference in the hand and
the specs and performance are just on
different levels so the pixels tensor
chip feels roughly equivalent to a
high-end Snapdragon 8 series maybe a
triple eight or an 865. the fairphone
has solid specs but definitely closer to
mid-range Snapdragon 750g and six or
eight gigs of RAM with 128 or 256 gigs
of storage that incredible removable
battery that I talked about it is 3 900
milliamp hours but that is smaller than
the 4600 that they fit into the pixel 6
and then the display while it's pretty
big and bright and covered in Gorilla
Glass 5 it would also be a relatively
weak point in a phone in this range at
1080p 60hz LCD phones like the pixel 6
would get you a larger brighter higher
refresh rate display that gets much
closer to the edges and is OLED with all
the color and feature benefits that come
with that and then of course we all know
about the pixel and its new cameras the
fair phone does have a 48 megapixel main
camera and a 48 megapixel Ultra wide and
a time of flight sensor in this array
back here but there there are acceptable
it looks kind of like a Moto G or a
Samsung a series phone where they'll
give you passable photos in decent light
but as soon as the conditions get tough
they kind of fall apart there is also a
slightly lesser ip54 Splash resistance
rating for this phone which is actually
kind of amazing for a phone built like
this but that is less than the ip68 the
full submersion protection for the pixel
there's also no wireless charging the
point is you know these two phones are
pretty similar functionally they're both
Android phones but as a customer
choosing to buy one you have to really
value the repairability and the
sustainability offered by the fair phone
to pick it over the pixel or really any
other phones in this range now part of
that is because it's hard to do all
those things in a super tightly built
Gadget and do all the repairability and
modularity on top of that but also the
other part is is a small company that
doesn't have the same resources to make
an incredible world-class bleeding edge
phone that's tightly packed and keep the
sustainability stuff in their supply
chain and keep the price competitive so
here's my take
there is no such thing as a 100 percent
sustainable phone like this like if you
go back far enough you'll find things
eventually that are imperfect so there
is no perfect sustainable smartphone but
the fair phone represents the furthest
anyone has ever gone by far there's a
lot of different materials that go into
building a smartphone plastic glass
aluminum nickel copper Fair phone goes
the extra mile to Source those build
materials fairly and responsibly which
definitely costs more so the back cover
of this phone like I mentioned is made
from 100 recycled plastic and over 50
percent of the plastic inside this phone
is post-consumer recycled then the
aluminum rails come from an ASI
certified vendor meaning worker health
and safety are protected and no child
labor is used and even for other mined
materials like tin and tungsten and the
lithium in the batteries that make sure
to invest in sustainable sources or use
mines that have been assessed by Irma
the initiative for responsible mining
Assurance but even so the world still
has a Cobalt shortage today so mining it
at all is not ideal we really should be
recycling it way more than we do but a
ton of the world's Cobalt is sitting in
drawers there's apparently 300 million
phones just sitting hibernating in
drawers right now doing nothing in just
Germany and France imagine how much that
scales up for the entire world and then
of course you can go even further and
further back like I can already see the
YouTube comments like well what about
the computers they're using to design
these are those sustainable what about
the buildings that they operate out of
where is there solar panels on the roof
of the studio they shut their
commercials in like nothing is 100
perfectly wholly sustainable and even
fairphone could do better there is no
charger in the Box in the pixel 6 and a
lot of their phones in that price range
and there's also no charger in the Box
for the fair phone but like I said
fairphone is setting the bar by going
farther than anybody else and even the
case that they're not perfect Fair phone
the company is pledging their entire
company to be E-Waste neutral meaning
for every phone they put out into the
market they collect an equal amount of
E-Waste that explains the slot in the
packaging where you can drop your
current device and send it back to them
to be recycled this is the most
sustainable phone in the world and it's
a real phone that you can buy and kinda
it's only available in Europe so to get
it to the US I had to import it but it's
real it's a real phone so it can be done
so the real question is this is one can
other phones be this sustainable too
yes and no so one Curious Thing That was
mentioned in fairphone's official video
when I was on their site is that they
have to in order to offer these five
years of replacement parts they have to
maintain a good relationship with those
parts vendors and their suppliers and so
they can't use two extreme or too low
Supply versions of Parts they need to
use mostly average parts so the phone
has to be an average size and use mostly
average specs like basically Fair phone
the company isn't big enough to be
designing every single thing inside
their own silicon their own image
sensors their own displays so they're
Bound by those suppliers and what they
can continually Supply but even for the
others these Mega companies out there
who don't have those same bounds
we are often rewarding the phones out
there that are pushing the limits that
are actually unique and that are
different for a change
that is by definition the opposite of
average that is the opposite of
sustainable but I still think there's
room
for these other companies to take parts
of what verifone is doing things like
not using a ton of glue and not using a
bunch of different complex screws and
just making their parts in general a bit
more accessible and more repairable and
thus a bit more sustainable so look I
don't think fairphone is ever expecting
to be a leader a global leader in
smartphone sales like they're never
going to pass Apple or Samsung or Huawei
or anything like that but what they are
doing is proving that there are real
ways for smartphone companies to do
better for all of those companies to
have better practices and even small
changes from those companies can make a
big difference so from here on out I
want to make a pledge to include some
section in all of my future smartphone
reviews on repairability and
sustainability just to shine a light on
that and give those companies a reason a
reward to make those compromises and as
for you and I we can do a much better
job of recycling our old electron
so uh do you have a smartphone sitting
in a drawer unused Gathering dust
recycle it
anyway we only have one Earth hot take
we should be taking better care of it
that's about it for this video thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one
peace
[Music]